>>> TOPPING OUR WORLD LEAD
TODAY, THE U.S. STATE DEPARTMENT
IS WORKING TO EXTRACT ABOUT 100
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND GREEN CARD
HOLDERS FROM AFGHANISTAN WHO SAY
THEY'RE READY TO LEAVE.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO A SENIOR
OFFICIAL AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
THOUSANDS MORE LEGAL PERMANENT
REPRESENTS OF THE U.S. AND
AFGHAN SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA
APPLICANTS REMAIN STUCK IN
AFGHANISTAN.
CNN'S ALEX MARQUARDT BRINGS UT
THE HARROWING STORY OF ONE
WOMAN'S DARING ESCAPE WITH THE
POSSIBLE HELP OF AMERICAN SPIES.
>> YOU GUYS LOOK, NO MORE FLAG.
>> AS THE TALIBAN TOOK OVER
AFGHANISTAN'S CAPITAL, SHAKIAK
WAS FILMING THE FIGHTERS FROM
HER BALCONY.
>> OKAY.
SO THEY ARE HERE TRYING TO GET
INTO THAT PERSON'S HOUSE.
>> Reporter: SHE WAS IN A
HIGH-RISE OVERLOOKING DOWNTOWN
KABUL AS AMERICAN AND NATO
FORCES WERE DESPERATELY TRYING
TO EVACUATE PEOPLE JUST LIKE
HER, AN AFGHAN AMERICAN WHO
WORKED FOR THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT
AND ON A U.S. FUNDED PROJECT.
BORN IN AFGHANISTAN AND MOVED TO
THE U.S. AT 13 YEARS OLD.
SHE RETURNED AS AN ADULT
SPENDING MOST OF THE PAST FOUR
YEARS WORKING WITH LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
NOW SHE'S BACK IN DENVER AFTER
TAKING PART IN ONE OF THE MOST
SECRETIVE OPERATIONS IN THE
ENTIRE EVACUATION, WHICH A U.S.
OFFICIAL TELLS CNN WAS IN PART
RUN BY THE CIA.
>> THE AIRPORT WAS ABSOLUTE
CHAOS.
IT WAS AS OF -- IF WE WOULD HAVE
HAD TO GO THROUGH DEATH VALLEY
IN ORDER TO MAKE AND SURVIVE.
>> SHE WAS IN HER APARTMENT WHEN
SHE GOT A CALL FROM AN AMERICAN.
I SAID WHO IS THIS, I'M A U.S.
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL!
NO DETAILS ABOUT WHO HE WORKED
FOR.
>> NOTHING AT ALL.
>> THE AMERICAN WANTED BARASHK
TO LEAVE BUT SHE SAID SHE WANTED
TO BRING AFGHANS WITH HER.
>> SHE SAID MY PRIORITY IS YOU,
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU FEEL THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TOWARDS THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE WORKED
WITH.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY MY PRIORITY IS
YOU.
>> Reporter: HOURS LATER, SHE
CHANGED HER MIND AFTER A FRIEND
WHO WAS EVACUATED CONVINCED HER.
>> I GRABBED MY PASSPORT AND
HEAD DOWNSTAIRS.
>> Reporter: A DRIVE IN TOYOTA
COROLLA PICKED HER UP BUT DIDN'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHERE TO GO.
TELL ME WHERE YOU ARE, THE
AMERICAN TEXTED, SHE SHARED HER
LOCATION AS THEY DROVE THROUGH
THE DARK AND TALIBAN CHECK
POINTS.
>> THE TALIBAN CAME AND SMASHED
THE FRONT OF THE CAR, AND WAVED,
AND SAID DON'T MOVE, STOP RIGHT
HERE, AND OUR DRIVER SAID I'M
NOT GOING TO LISTEN TO HIM.
>> Reporter: THE AMERICAN
OFFICIAL WAS TRACKING THEM.
I SEE YOU, JUST FOLLOW THE ROAD
UNTIL YOU SEE A GAS STATION,
THEN YOU WILL SEE MY GUYS.
>> I WASN'T SCARED BECAUSE I
DIDN'T HAVE THE TIME TO BE
SCARED.
BEING SCARED WAS NOT AN OPTION.
>> Reporter: THEY WENT THE WRONG
WAY.
THE AMERICAN TEXTED, YOU MISSED
LEFT TURN.
AROUND MIDNIGHT, THEY FINALLY
ARRIVED AT EAGLE BASE, A CIA
BASE JUST EAST OF KABUL, LOCATED
BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHERE
HELICOPTERS WERE FERRYING PEOPLE
INSIDE TO THE AIRPORT.
BARASHK WAS MET BY AFGHAN
SPECIAL FORCES AND THEN
AMERICANS, INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN GUIDING HER.
I MENTIONED HIS NAME, AND SAID
IS THAT YOU, HE SAID, YES,
THAT'S ME, THERE WAS A SIGH OF
RELIEF AT THAT POINT.
WE MADE IT.
THERE'S NO MORE CHECK POINTS.
>> Reporter: ON THE BASE, THEIR
PHONES WERE TAKEN AWAY.
THEY WERE ASKED NOT TO REVEAL
THE BASE'S LOCATION.
THE NEXT DAY THEY WERE FLOWN TO
KABUL AIRPORT AND OUT OF THE
COUNTRY TO SAFETY.
WHAT DO YOUR FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE STILL IN
KABUL, STIG STLL IN AFGHANISTANL
YOU ABOUT WHAT THEY THINK THE
FUTURE IS GOING TO BE LIKE?
>> THEY SAY AFGHANISTAN IS A
BODY WITHOUT A SOUL, SEEING THE
WAY THAT EVERYTHING THAT THEY
HAD WORKED FOR THE PAST 20 YEARS
HAS BEEN JUST SHATTERED IN FRONT
OF THEIR OWN EYES.
THE PROMISES OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY NEVER
LEAVING THEM BEHIND AND NOW
THEY'RE LEFT WITH NOTHING.
>> Reporter: SHE SAYS SHE AND
OTHERS LIKE HER ARE NOW
SUFFERING FROM SIGNIFICANT
SURVIVORS GUILT.
>> TO THIS DAY, I'M STILL
PROCESSING THE INFORMATION AND
PROCESSING THE REALITY ON THE
GROUND.
IT JUST FEELS LIKE IT'S A
ONGOING NIGHTMARE THAT I HAVEN'T
BEEN WOKEN UP FROM.
>> AND SHE TOLD ME SHE FELT
BLESSED AND PRIVILEGED TO HAVE
BEEN EVACUATED THE WAY THAT SHE
WAS, AS SHE SAYS, JAKE, WITHOUT
A SCRATCH.
SHE KNOWS THAT IS NOT THE CASE
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE WHO TRIED,
AND SOME WHO DID GET OUT FROM
THE AIRPORT IN KABUL, AND
OTHERS, MANY THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS, WHO STILL WANT TO GET
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN!
>> DOES THE STATE DEPARTMENT
HAVE AN IDEA OF NOT JUST HOW
MANY AMERICAN CITIZENS, LEGAL
RESIDENTS, GREEN CARD HOLDERS
WANT TO GET OUT.
DO THEY HAVE A NUMBER?
>> THEY HAVE A FIRMER NUMBER
ABOUT THOSE WHO HAVE EXPRESSED
DESIRES TO GET OUT LESS SO IN
THE OVERALL POPULATION, SO THEY
SAY NO, TODAY, STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS SAID THERE ARE AROUND
100 AMERICANS AND LEGAL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS WHO ARE
READY TO LEAVE.
THAT NUMBER IS CONSTANTLY IN
FLUX BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE CHANGING
THEIR MINDS.
THERE ARE MANY MORE AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHO LIVE THERE WHO
DON'T WANT TO LEAVE, MANY WHO DO
TO WANT LEAVE AND CAN'T.